quand on regarde tout ça est ce que vous
voyez ce que vous avez déjà fait ou ce
qui vous reste à faire
oui je vois quand je regarde tout ce qui
tout quand je fais le tour du château
je vois ce qui a été fait certes non
sens rappelle pas trop bien joué surtout
ce qui reste à faire
il ya toujours plein de projets donc on
ne pense qu'à ce qu'on va faire
ce qui va être réalisable dans
l'immédiat là pour l'instant on est sur
le projet de la chapelle c'est un projet
qui avance bien et c'est une vraie
satisfaction que que ce projet puisse
arriver à terme le prochain gros morceau
si j'ose dire sont les deux tours
carrées après la chapelle donc on
envisage sa dès les années 2020 2021
c'est vrai qu'il ya une urgence sur les
tours carrées non seulement elle pose
quand même quelques soucis de sts de
solidité mais aussi ce sont des endroits
qui sont extrêmement rares trouver une
tour carrée xiième siècle entière et
dans son état de construction d'origine
c'est très rare donc à à protéger
absolument et si on peut les rendre
accessibles
pourquoi pas mais là c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau alors ya 25 ans quand je vous
avais rencontré je vous avais demandé si
vous aviez une idée de l'argent qui
avait été engloutie dans ces lieux vous
même v10 non alors aujourd'hui je sais
toujours pas plus que c'est pas évident
de de convertir les sommes les jambes
l'outil c'était en francs maintenant en
euro et par rapport au coût de la vie
c'est pas évident mais on peut dire
peut-être
oui entre 1 2 million d'euros peut-être
déjà investi dans ce lieu peut-être des
travaux de plus en plus importants
havrais chacun en fait 1,2 million non
mais c'est le nom parce que
faudrait comparer et
la valeur d'aujourd'hui mais ça fait
tout de même 50 ans que ça dure donc un
petit peu chaque année c'est vrai que
chaque année on arrive à faire près de
50 à 80 mille euros de travaux donc
c'est tout à fait énorme pour nous à
notre échelle
vous bénéficiez dette de l'état de la
région du département
si on arrive à faire des trous aussi
important ce parce qu'on bénéficie des
deux le château est classée donc classé
monument historique donc au niveau de
l'état il ya des aides très importantes
la région est sensible au patrimoine est
cette année particulièrement devrait
apporter une aide assez considérable le
département de haute soule nous aide
également on en est très fière et en
échange on est aussi un lieu visité donc
une belle image du département
un échange de bons procédés et quand on
a rassemblé toutes ces sommes
y compris les bénéfices sur les visites
du château une association importante
qui donne le coup de main le mécénat
juste à nous permet justement
d'envisager au moins je vous dis 50 à 80
mille euros de travaux chaque année ce
qui est énorme alors être classé
monument historique c'est aussi beaucoup
de contraintes ça ça vous embête pas
trop ça peut sembler être une contrainte
mais ça ne l'est pas une puisque tout le
monde va dans le même sens le rôle de
l'état c'est de veiller à ce que les les
monuments perdurer soit à peu près
entretenu correctement et le rôle du
propriétaire c'est le même donc ça ne ça
ne devrait pas poser de
deux problèmes le seul le seul souci
quelquefois on a envie de les travaux se
fassent rapidement et dans les démarches
administratives sont quelquefois un peu
plus longue mais est il ya une toujours
une très bonne entente entre les
services de la drac de la conservation
des monuments historiques et les lieux
et les lieux donc ça se passe plus pour
très bien je me suis laissé dire que dès
l'âge de 12 13 ans vous passiez pour un
illuminé
parce que vous disiez je vais sauver le
château de ricaud ben je passais un oui
pour un illuminé parce que pour d autres
enfants de 12 13 ans je pense qu'on a
d'autres préoccupations de jouer au foot
de partir en vacances de faire n'importe
quoi et et là oui ça pouvait passer un
petit peu c'est un petit peu oui bizarre
pour les autres enfants
mais aujourd'hui je les revois ces gens
là ils reviennent visiter et ils me
disent tu te rappelles deux mois
évidemment ça fait 50 ans que les ai pas
vus bien sûr mais auprès auprès des
adultes aussi ça pouvait comment comment
croire à un tel discours venant d'un
enfant je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas
très sérieux c'est juste un discours
d'enfants personnes retraite de graisse
vous l'avez réaliser oui bien sûr enfin
cet envoi parce que ça met toujours
beaucoup plus de temps que prévu
1 je pense va je pensais pas en arriver
là parce que c'est pas évident de mener
à la fois une vie professionnelle enfin
professionnels n'exagérons rien juste
travailler de quoi nourrir sa famille et
prendre le temps et trouver les moyens
de sauver une telle maison et pour vous
ce sera fini quand ce sera jamais fini
parce que de toute façon il y aura
toujours des choses à entretenir le but
n'est pas de refaire à châteauneuf c'est
c'est pas du tout dans l'air du temps
le but c'est de l'empêcher de s'abîmer
plus et de le rendre accessible
aux visiteurs en toute sécurité et ça
c'est déjà très ambitieux mais on pourra
considérer que le lieu d'à peu près
sauvé quand tous les murs d'enceinte et
les tours seront protégés bien sûr vous
vous sentez un peu seigneur de temps en
temps mais évidemment non la vie de
château c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on
croit c'est à dire que le but c'est
toujours d'organiser travaux on est
sollicité pour des visites ou autres
animations
on y passe beaucoup de temps on n'a pas
le temps de prendre du recul ni de
profiter pleinement du lieu il ne m'est
jamais arrivé de prendre une chaise
longue et un livre au milieu de la cour
alors que c'est un endroit
extraordinaire mais il ya toujours eu il
ya toujours quelque chose à faire
qui vous empêche de prendre le temps de
profiter du lieu mais on en profite à
travers ce qu'on fait à travers les
visites
je veux dire les les visiteurs sondés
sont des miroirs qui vous renvoie qui
renvoie plein de choses sur sur ce
qu'ils apprécient dans le lieu et ça
c'est extrêmement plaisant